Ben Affleck is out of rehab ET has
learned that the 46 year old actor is
back home and preparing for a new movie
role after a stay at a treatment
facility
according to the source he is committed
to his sobriety this includes focusing
on his family and getting back to work
our source adds quote Ben will stay in
treatment for the foreseeable future
he'll continue to work with a sober
coach attend therapy and meditation
classes
Affleck has been in a Malibu California
rehab facility for more than a month and
it seems the time has done him good on
Monday he was spotted walking through a
parking lot in LA and can we say holy
Batman something more
something darker the Justice League star
gave off major superhero vibes with his
jacked broad-shouldered barrel-chested
physique Affleck looked even better than
he did the day before when he attended
church with ex-wife Jennifer Garner and
their three children this of course is a
far cry from his disheveled appearance
around the time he first entered
treatment back in August
Benton's brother Casey opened up to et
last month about his brothers struggle
with sobriety my father is an alcoholic
as bad as you can be and he's been sober
for about thirty years I've been sober
for about six years and man is trying to
put it together and it's it can be a
very hard thing to do and he has the
kind of resources in time luckily to
take the time and to go to a good
facility and you know it has a
alcoholism has a huge impact on not just
the person but also their family and so
I think for his kids sake and for their
mom I think he's and for himself he's
trying to do the work and as for Ben's
new movie role et has learned Affleck
will play a former basketball star who's
struggled with addiction and is
attempting a comeback in the upcoming
film torrents which was previously known
as the has-been
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]